moi je sais pas moi qui passe les
contrats comme vous le savez je rappeler
non il ya un code des marchés publics
vous avez des milliers d'acheteurs dans
l'état et comme il y en a d'ailleurs
dans toutes les collectivités publiques
qui ont recontre non président de la
république n'autorise qu'elle aucune
dépense ça pour le coup les choses sont
claires dans la constitution un ministre
est à la tête de son administration il
ya un contrôle ensuite par la cour des
comptes elle parlement mais on a dit
beaucoup de bêtises ces derniers jours
on a parlé du milliard
je vous invite à regarder le détail les
trois quarts même plus je compte la
ministre élections des comptes publics a
évoqué ce sont des recours à des
prestataires informatiques et des
entreprises pour financer le cyber et
l'évolution aux nouveaux risques l'état
a parfois besoin d'avoir des compétences
extérieures qui ont travaillé auprès
d'autres pays pour justement faire face
à ses missions et d'ailleurs je vous
invite à regarder les dépenses de tous
nos voisins au moment de la crise qu
vide ou face à des nouvelles menaces
comme le cyber ils ont des chiffres qui
sont la plupart du temps bien supérieurs
à ceux de la france je me félicite que
on est des compétences en soi mais quand
on veut accélérer aller très vite et
très fort sur une politique qu'il faut
parfois avoir recours à des prestataires
extérieurs à l'état il ne faut pas tout
confondre
donc je souhaite que ce débat soit un
débat éclairé où chacun justifie de sa
dépense je ne vais pas moi justifier de
chaque contrat je ne les connais pas et
pas moi qui les ai passées mais
il faut poser la question au ministre
qu'il a passée voit son administration
je ne suis pas d'éditeur de la chef
d'entreprise qui vient parler devant le
sénat fo oranges et quand même toutes
les cases là sinon on va dire tout à la
montée
mais personne ne décide à la place
mais attendez on va on va repartir à la
base vous pouvez avoir recours à des
prestataires extérieurs quand vous avez
une entreprise ou quand vous avez une
administration une collectivité locale
d'ailleurs je vous invite à regarder
tous vos employeurs le fond
que vous soyez veux que vous venez de
groupe d'audiovisuel public ou privé
tous le font parce qu'il ya des missions
parfois ponctuelles vous n'avez pas les
compétences en interne parce qu'il ya
des choses que d'autres fonds et y'a pas
les compétences en interne donc ça on va
pas commencer à rentrer dans un débat de
fou qui consisterait à dire que on n'a
plus le droit d'avoir recours à des
prestataires extérieurs
on aura tous un problème premier point
je vous invite à regarder les chiffres
période longue je me félicite que sous
ce quinquennat on est beaucoup moins
dépensé qui a 10 ans et je vous invite à
regarder la tendance il ya eu une
augmentation covit parce qu'il eut
besoin et parce que en particulier aussi
sur l'équipement en cyber on a augmenté
mais je vous invite à regarder les
périodes antérieures
travail et regarder les chiffres en
france depuis 15 ans dites moi si ce
quinquennat est un quinquennat où on a
beaucoup augmenté vous verrez que c'est
le contraire regardez ce qu'il ya
derrière ces dépenses et vous verrez que
l'essentiel c'est les dépenses liées à
la crise et de nouveaux risques sur
lesquels n'y avait pas des compétences
d'état et enfin en méthode ça n'est
jamais celui qui conseille qui décident
trouve que dans la ville dans mes vies
intérieures jai pu conseiller c'est
celui qui passe une commande qui décide
il n'y a pas les compétences pour
répondre quelqu'un eut fait la réponse
est celle est clair il choisit donc
voila mais je pense qu'il faut savoir
raison garder après si il y a des choses
qui ne sont pas justifiées il ya des
responsabilités qui doivent être activés
je pense qu'il faut pas rentrer dans un
débat où en quelque sorte on viendrait
en france se priver
l'état le gouvernement français devrait
se priver de compétences que d'autres
gouvernements peuvent acquérir mise de
la santé le rap et quelques jours ceux
qui ont accompagné gouvernement allemand
ou autre dont tous vous me disiez début
janvier 2020 2021 ils vont beaucoup plus
vite en vaccination ils ont une très
bonne organisation on a été content
qu'on puisse avoir recours pour des
sommes raisonnables au cabinet qui avait
accompagné les allemands pour transférer
la technologie et pour qu'on le fasse
mieux ça ça ne me choque pas et je vous
invite à regarder les beaucoup des
politiques qui sont en train de
commenter président ou présidente de
région ont recours à des cabinets de
conseil comme ça ils le font ils le font
et la question vous vous devez vous
poser ou temps mais sont confiantes au
oui mais vous allez voir et on l'a vu il
ya des hôpitaux qui ont été attaquées
par les risques cyber aujourd'hui notre
système hospitalier il n'est pas protégé
vous avez un hôpital français personne
ne sait ce que c'est que le cyber dans
l'état en a pas assez d'équipement est
ce que je vais vous dire je vais
embaucher des fonctionnaires et les
former pour que dans cinq ans soit le
rendez vous non s'il ya des cabinets qui
savent le faire c'est plus intelligent
de prendre un cabinet
[Musique]